for fortnight players have been banned
for 60 days after epic games determined
they were cheating in this past
weekend's fortnight championship series
matches but this particular cheating
situation has the community divided
because it's not as straightforward as
aimbots or wallhacks let me break the
whole situation down for you
[Music]
okay let's start from the beginning so
four guys got banned but what did they
do well they got caught teaming in like
12 consecutive lobbies but what does
that mean well don't worry I'm gonna get
to that but first the F n CS that's for
tonight's online weekly competitive
tournament series and in that world of
competitive fortnight there's a lot of
pressure to build mechanics into the
game that allow players to fight early
and often because let's be honest if
you're a viewer and you're trying to
watch the best fortnight players in the
world you don't want to see them boxed
up all game you want to see them
fighting and getting into these crazy
build battles and that's actually where
this particular issue starts with
something called storm surge okay quick
recap what storm surge is after the
second time the movies is pocky yourself
there can only be a certain amount of
people more than a certain amount of
people alive players which means if
you're camping or boxed up you've got to
get out of that pillow fort you've built
and start fighting and there was that
exact mechanic that the players being
accused cRIO bucks locks and keys abused
this past weekend and after those two
duo's took both the first and second
slots in this week's f n CS action claim
started to circle on Twitter that they
were potentially team here's exactly
what they did basically every game they
would land in the same spot lewd up and
then engaged just a little they would
deal just enough damage so that storm
surge wouldn't be a problem but never a
full-on engagement never like looking
for kills
[Music]
now in the world of competitive
fortnight it's not actually unusual for
teams to drop in the same spot every
game because mastering a looting spot is
actually a big part of preparing for
competitive events so that means when
you're playing competitive tournaments
you're gonna be seeing the same people
off your drop quite often but to a lot
of the competitive community reacting to
these clips online this all just seemed
a little too perfect they dropped in
every game loot it up and had these
small skirmishes but it never turned
into a real fight this all just seemed a
little too convenient so naturally
people online were a little skeptical
and this includes one of the winningest
players in fortnight history bizzle who
reposted the original accusation and
after all the matches finished on Sunday
night epic games well they seem to agree
with the accusers because they
immediately banned these guys here's the
specific rule that epic says that they
broke in order to land these 60-day bans
players may not work together to deceive
or otherwise cheat other players during
any match examples of collusion include
the following teaming players working
together during the match while on
opposing teams planned movement
agreement between two or more opposing
players to land at specific locations or
to move through the map in a planned way
before the match begins communication
sending or receiving signals both verbal
or nonverbal to communicate with
opposing players or item dumping
intentionally dropping items for an
opposing player to collect and yeah
obviously what these four guys did fits
pretty well into this ruling so this
ruling the 60-day ban it actually
eliminates all four players from the
rest of the full season of F NCS
and of course since ethics ruling went
public all four of these players have
made statements defending their place
look obviously the guys that got banned
are gonna defend themselves
but what's really surprising here is
that they're not the only ones Pro fires
like clicks have come to their defense
and saying that even if they did cheat
epic games acted way too quickly and
didn't give them a chance to defend
themselves and after all this drama went
down on Sunday you knew it was gonna
spill over into Monday on social media
and I'm other than the voices condemning
these players were two of fortnight's
biggest stars t foo and ninjas I guess
we finally found something these guys
can agree
I respect mongrel and Benji fishy and
those guys man I don't think that I
don't think they would do this there's
so they're too talented they're too
talented they don't need to and I'm
disappointed man 60 days was like too
much I agree with them if they only did
it for one game but they [ __ ] did it
for like nine [ __ ] games in a row
like what the [ __ ] oh now you've got to
remember that when competitive fortnight
was in its early days there was actually
a lot of hate on epic for not acting
swiftly or strongly enough when it came
to cheaters but over the last few months
first by banning Jarvis for his little
aimbot crusade and now with this
incident epic doesn't seem scared of
laying down the hammer obviously The
Situation's pretty complicated but if
they did cheat and it does look to me
like they did consequences should be
fast and effective with that said this
eliminates them from the entirety of the
f n CS season and the five million
dollar prize pool that comes with it
which begs the question does the
punishment fit the crime
I guess I'd rather it this way then the
competitive scene be overrun by cheers I
like saying a lot I think baseball
movies in general are underrated like a
lot of times like when people talk about
the like best sports movies ever it's
always like like basketball or football
movies like Remember the Titans or like
Coach Carter like the Hoosiers that sort
of thing but baseball
movies are so fun and they'd like like
that they're always like they take
themselves a little less seriously than
that kind of stuff which I always like